there was this sort of dust up about the
definition of recession in Wikipedia
so the accusation was and the accusation
was often quite ridiculous and extreme
which is under pressure from the Biden
Administration Wikipedia changed the
definition of recession to make Biden
look good or we did it not under
pressure but because we're a bunch of
lunatic leftists and so on and then you
know when I see something like that in
the Press I'm like oh dear like what's
happened here how did we do that because
I always just accept things for five
seconds first and then I go and I look
and I'm like you know what that's
literally completely not what happened
what happened was one editor thought the
article needed restructuring so the
article is always said so the the
traditional kind of loose definition of
recession is two quarters of negative
growth
but there's always been within economics
within important agencies in different
countries around the world a lot of
nuance around that and there's other
like factors that go into it and so
forth and it's just an interesting
complicated topic
and so the article has always had the
definition of two quarters the only
thing that really changed was moving
that from the lead from the top
paragraph to further down and then news
stories appeared saying uh Wikipedia has
changed the definition of recession and
then we got a huge rush of trolls coming
in so the article was temporarily
protected I think only semi-protected
and people were told go to the talk Pace
to discuss so it was a dust up that was
you know when you look at it as a
Wikipedia and you're like oh like this
is a really routine kind of editorial
debate